este es el boy bomba el mayor festival
folclórico de la amazonía
[Aplausos]
una ópera tropical basada en leyendas
indígenas y lleno de referencias a una
naturaleza exuberante
tras dos años de pandemia está de vuelta
durante tres noches la isla amazónica de
parent ins se convierte en un enorme
campo de batalla entre dos bueyes el
garantido y el caprichoso
el festival de parintins es el mejor
festival del mundo es una fiesta de dos
bueyes que están enamorados de dos
colores el rojo y el azul el rojo es un
buen blanco lindo que roba el corazón
[Música]
estos dos grupos folclóricos disputan el
título de campeón en el bombo dromo una
arena construida hace 34 años en el
corazón de la selva para dar vida a este
espectáculo grandioso
la preparación del festival dura varios
meses en abril los artistas de cada
grupo comienzan a construir sus
esculturas gigantescas en vísperas de la
presentación las acoplan en la puerta
del bombo dromo es muy complejo porque
ninguno de nosotros los artistas somos
ingenieros no estudiamos en la
universidad somos autodidactas
aprendimos a ejecutar para este proceso
de construcción de las figuras
alegóricas en los galpones de parintins
las figuras alegóricas de parent ins son
famosas por su movilidad son necesarias
8 personas para maniobrar los cables y
dar vida a este felino por esta razón
estos artistas son muy solicitados
algunos trabajan en el carnaval de río
de janeiro e incluso en uruguay
además sí preocupan por la
sustentabilidad de la fiesta ya tenemos
nuestras propias técnicas existen unos
materiales que siempre reutilizamos
mayoría de las figuras alegóricas están
hechas con aquellos sacos que vienen de
china mercancías importadas en el puerto
franco de manaus
el boy bomba es una importante fuente de
ingresos para paran team es una ciudad
de 115 mil habitantes ubicada en una
isla del río amazonas en la última
edición atrajo a 66 mil turistas y
genera unos ingresos de 10 millones de
dólares la presentación del festival
tiene una temática indígena tiene
momentos tribales en otra habla de
ecología bosques en la importancia de
los indígenas para nuestra cultura
realmente el festival difunde nuestra
cultura en el mundo un detalle curioso
todas las plumas son sintéticas y son
importadas desde china
las personas que son descubiertas con
plumas naturales son multadas
dependiendo de la cantidad por eso
optamos por trabajar con una cosa bonita
de calidad
que se aproxima lo máximo posible a las
plumas naturales
en este ambiente festivo la pregunta es
dónde se habrá metido el buey lo
encontramos en este taller donde recibe
los últimos retoques ponga
durante tres décadas marquinho ha sido
el animador del boy caprichoso el famoso
tree para cada agrupación tiene varios
artistas porque ahí abajo hace 60 grados
son dos horas y media de espectáculos
conseguimos aguantar mucho tiempo porque
nos preparamos para eso hacemos muchos
movimientos tenemos una excelente forma
física y resistencia
toda la familia trabaja en la confección
del buey hace tiempo marquinho pasó el
testigo a su hijo
toda la fiesta acontece en función del
buey los hinchas acuden para animar la
competición ellos vibran se emocionan
por eso es conocido como el rey de la
fiesta
[Aplausos]
llega
alguien dijo emoción durante toda la
semana para ti está totalmente dividida
entre los azules y los rojos es una
guerra de colores
yo planifiqué durante años este viaje
5000 kilómetros de carreteras 1500
kilómetros de navegación
después de dos años sin festival estamos
aquí con mucha guerra la nación roja y
blanca está todo aquí este título es
nuestro
unos 35.000 espectadores asistieron cada
noche al espectáculo con el corazón en
la mano
[Música]
y al final ganó el boy caprichoso que
concluyó su primer espectáculo con un
homenaje al periodista don phillips y el
indigenista bruno pereyra ambos
asesinados por luchar a favor de la
manzanilla